this morning on our reddit discussion
forum or subreddit some people hate it
when I call it a reddit discussion forum
I know that it's just a subreddit but
for people who are not reddit savvy I
want to use a term that would explain to
them what it is because like a subreddit
doesn't really tell you what it is so I
like to say this is where people can
discuss stuff I like both terms it's
good for word choice yeah you got to
switch it up everything right exactly
otherwise I end up using the word vile a
hundred times in a show and we we know
how that goes a very interesting
discussion about a Sam cedar majority
report commentary on Jordan Peterson's
recent appearance on Real Time with Bill
Maher and his people on this program
know I have been a significant critic of
Jordan Peterson I think that he has one
of the most sophisticated forms of sort
of anti sjw self-help type nonsense that
really appeals to a big contingent of
the internet mail world I don't I don't
even know what to call it and in any
case Sam cedar doing a very good job of
picking apart
Peterson's appearance on Real Time with
Bill Maher which I watched and a lot of
people in our audience liking and some
not liking sam cedars commentary also
from the subreddit another addition to
the david pakman show drinking turned
bingo game a spot on the board should be
reserved for any time David segues into
a new topic by saying hey this is sort
of weird yeah I do say that a lot
sometimes you don't know how to
introduce a new topic and or I don't
know and I will say something like hey
this is sort of weird Donald Trump was
caught in another lie about the PP tape
or whatever I just don't know how else
to introduce some of these well you have
your go-to yeah
and I think one of them is I think
you're gonna like this I think you're
gonna like this yeah that's another one
that I do like I think that that's fair
for the bingo board to have hey this is
weird as a as a show segue so very very
perceptive also major major tumult as a
result of producer Pat caught on camera
during a split screen moment agreeing
with me in a way that I guess some
people are arguing seems a little bit
disingenuous like I think that's the
criticism we're gonna put up on the
screen pat agreeing with something I was
saying and nodding and then sort of
putting his
chin to hand or hand to chin in a sort
of thinking man's position and a couple
people picking this up and one actually
doing more of like a zoom in on Pat when
he was doing this agreeing motion can
you explain Pat whether this like is
that a disingenuous agreement where
you're sort of like by nodding in a very
unusual way implying you don't agree
with me well I do that a lot
I'd have to like go back and play the
video yeah see what we were actually
talking about because I honestly don't
know
you know remember yeah but I think that
I think that looks pretty genuine no
really I don't know it strikes me as
pretty disingenuous but I think that
we'll leave it to the audience to decide
but yeah going back to the video would
be useful but interestingly multiple
people picking up on the fact that at a
certain point during Monday's show Pat
was agreeing it's almost like nodding
your head yes while your eyes
communicate panic that you actually
don't agree with what's going on it's
sort of like an equivalent people also
like how we were wearing the same shirt
yeah like it's cute you know yeah yeah
that's I'm home and change at the top
every different day check it out at
david pakman.com slash reddit
participate about 6,000 of our viewers
and listeners now regularly discussing
politics there